I was a hell of a good artist a world
war two illustrator and now I can barely
write my name
[Music]
I heard what happened to you five of
them jumped him to miracle he survived
[Music]
you taking your meds
I got beaten with an inch of my life for
no reason one foot in front of other you
got it mark I embrace the pain but I've
created a world where I can heal what is
all of this
welcome to Marwan it's my art
installation you're an artist that's a
complicated story
let's huh me you really want to know yes
they kicked every memory I ever had out
of my head everything from before the
attacks come so my dolls have to tell
the story these are the women of Marwan
and they protect mark were one on the
same pal from the bad guys
let's go
I thought I heard you yelling for more
gumbo not gumbo no gumbo are all of the
Tollison Marwin people you know
yeah there's Anna yeah Julie hell yeah
Karl Allah you can't keep on running
away from your problems Roberta are you
gonna go to the sentencing you need to
face those jerks who beat you up not
really sure how to do this her pain is
our rocket fuel the life I once had was
taken away from me but I'm still here
I have hope and I have my town and I
have my friends I got your back
it'll be okay
[Music]
anything is possible in Marlon bottoms
up girl
people need to see how special Marwin
really is to life to love to the women
of Marwan
you
[Music]
you